[Music]
did you
Oh
[Music]
hey that's gum Braz my green PewDiePie
great admirers here we're gonna play Bop
It
I never played it before and if you
don't know basically you do what he says
I had to twist it pull it pop but we're
gonna play it a real way there's a twist
hey look it's cutie pie cool
oh wow thank you thank you predefined
number three if you found your nipples
one yeah like you want to begin I want
you to be these are actual nipple clamps
Hey oh this is gonna suck don't go too
hard
all right just go up a little bit all
right you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm lucky fell
out because he needs a circuit to work
here we go you ready okay [ __ ] panic
attack
okay if you're gonna pump it just do
that don't move that fine
I'm not good enough to do that and shut
the [ __ ] up when your bath it's like I
know I took it starting this time
I'll be bored pin Brad down put it on
this down right in the comments if you
think we should testicle Brad no ah
but thank you guys so much for watching
this video if you liked it punch Felix
in the face whenever you meet him on the
street and high-fives all around
see you later
[Music]